ce visage celui de marie laure
c'est un des visages comme celui de tumi
celui de gmail celui de kader de
christian les farid que toute la france
a découvert dans les jours qui viennent
de passer
c'est le visage des marcheurs qui parti
de marseille le 15 octobre sont arrivés
à paris le 3 décembre au terme d'un
périple de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres
cette marche pour l'égalité nous avons
essayé de vous la restituer à travers
cette émission de ce matin entièrement
consacré à cette aventure un peu hors du
commun
cette initiative partie d'un quartier de
lyon les minguettes et qui de la cayolle
à marseille jusqu'à la bastille à
montparnasse a permis à un certain
nombre de français de prendre conscience
du problème que pouvait créer dans ce
pays
le racisme
[Musique]
pour la main
l'humour disait le poète c'est la
politesse du désespoir la violence 10
les minguettes
c'est le bagne des exclus avec le ghetto
pour ligne d'horizon
un habitat en forme de meurtrières une
scolarité qui conforte les inégalités
une formation qui se dérobe un emploi
qui se refuse le chômage complice de
l'oise yves t au seuil de leur vie
d'adulte
deux jeunes garçons ont refusé
l'engrenage de la violence et de la
haine du mozaïc étaient présents en
février de cette année lorsque jamel
toumi et leurs camarades desilets de
réagir et de s'organiser bientôt sos à
venir minguettes aller voir le jour
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
et
oh
mais avant que ne se réalise la
prophétie la route pavée d'intention
généreuse est aussi semer d'embûches
serait ce une fatalité de l'histoire qui
veut que les messi doivent toujours
triomphé d'une succession d'épreuves la
bonne parole ne serait-elle entendu
qu'au prix des larmes et du sang lorsque
la société trébuche pourquoi incriminer
celui qui ferme la marche
lorsque la société prend froid pourquoi
désigner du doigt celui qui est le moins
couverts mohamed bou fait mouche 53 ans
abdenbi gamme ya 19 ans yazid rory 23
ans nous ça m'évoque 19 ans toufik oi
naissent 9 ans mohamed rabbae 11 ans
massemba badiane 12 ans zineb sadi 30
ans habib renzi 26 ans entre 1982 et
plus de cinquante crimes et agressions
racistes sont commis visant des
adolescents parfois même des enfants
inspirés des exemples de martin luther
king et de gandhi farouk patrick fatima
le pasteur jean costil le père christian
delorme et le service oecuménique
d'entraidé de la cimade des amis du
mouvement pour une alternative non
violente décide une grande croisade de
la paix à laquelle se joignent sans
frontières et d'autres collectifs le
projet d'une marche pacifique pour
l'égalité prendra naissance autour du
lit d'hôpital de tumi djidja victime
d'un policier le 20 juin 1983
j'étais désespéré
de mes frais aux sondages
je voyais
[Musique]
l'avenir à genoux la baie de rio
le pied au sud ce 15 octobre 1983
ils sont une trentaine au rendez-vous de
la cayolle à marseille
la même route en mars dernier deux
enfants de gitans étaient victimes de la
haine aveugle
en ces instants mémorables le doute
assaille les esprits sera ton entendu
écouté compris le 22 long rifle et la
psychose de l'insécurité
n'ont-ils pas déjà creusé le fossé mais
l'appréhension se dissipe avec les
premières manifestations d'intérêt et de
sympathie non c'est bien l'espoir qui
habitent les coeurs et qui accompagnent
les premiers pas de plus pour une fois
le dialogue se fera dans le sens
sud/nord 50 jours pour parcourir 12 à 15
100 km 30 km chaque jour pour convaincre
une france que beaucoup vont découvrir
pour la première fois le même jour à
paris sur le parvis de beaubourg
ils sont deux sens du collectif jeunes
de la région parisienne à manifester
leur solidarité avec les marcheurs tout
au long des deux premières semaines
l'indifférence la provocation parfois
ont semé le doute
le découragement s'emparera de quelques
marcheurs mais l'étape de lyon va
constituer le tournant décisif de la
marche
elle va galvaniser les énergies et
grossir les rangs
est ce la vertu du retour aux sources
toujours est il qu'ils sont plus de 300
sur le plateau de vénissieux les
minguettes la marche pour l'égalité est
désormais placé sur orbite la dynamique
du succès est engagé
j'en ai tendu qui s'en allait
[Musique]
que du feu
ils se font autant
de si peu
qu'ils avaient si peu de colère
j'entends leurs pages entre l'ordre
il est des choses banales
[Musique]
vision d'un journal comme on en lit le
soir chez soi
je confesse
au mieux
budget
et vos droits parentaux prix
on
pour la majorité des jeunes la frontière
de la zup marqué jusque là les limites
de la france
la marche pour l'égalité a éclairci la
ligne de l'horizon
elle a permis la mise en contact
d'univers sociaux et deux milieux qui
n'avait jamais communiquer entre eux
l'esprit du mouvement c'est bien sûr les
marcheurs mais c'est aussi les dizaines
de comités de soutien répartis sur les
50 villes qui jalonnent le parcours
jusqu'à paris en charge de l'accueil et
de l'intendance les comités de soutien
constitue un rouage essentiel de la
marche
c'est en effet par leurs actions avant
pendant et après la marche que
rencontres et échanges s'effectuent
animations et débats met en perspective
les réalités et les revendications au
plan local avec l'esprit et la
philosophie de la marche
au fur et à mesure que la marge
progresse les soutiens et les marques de
solidarité sont de plus en plus nombreux
les marcheurs découvrent une france du
coeur citadins ou paysans hommes ou
femmes adolescents ou enfants
ils ont choisi de saisir la main tendue
rencontre anecdotes et souvenirs image
et impression participe d'une nouvelle
mémoire ici et là des élus locaux de
l'opposition comme de la majorité
accueille les marcheurs ici le recours
aux slogans s'efface au bénéfice de
l'explication et du dialogue autour des
thèmes de la marche
m
600 kilomètres parcourus depuis
marseille plus de vingt mille personnes
ont déjà accompagné les marcheurs
le moral est au beau fixe d'autant que
les nages des anoraks offerts lors des
dernières étapes permettent de résister
au vent et au froid des personnalités
commencent à se joindre aux marcheurs à
mulhouse
c'était monsieur edmond maire le
secrétaire général de la cfdt à
strasbourg c'était au tour de madame
georgina dufoix secrétaire d'état à la
famille à la population et aux
travailleurs immigrés
une délégation de marcheurs étaient
reçus au siège du conseil de l'europe
attentif à un mouvement qui se reconnaît
dans la charte des droits de l'homme
[Musique]
l'itinéraire de la marche a bien sûr
privilégier les villes et les régions où
vivent les communautés immigrées
aussi chaque étape at-elle été
l'occasion d'une information qui a
identifié la situation socio économique
des immigrés comme l'obstacle majeur à
une meilleure cohabitation la dimension
culturelle était également présente et
les animations en soirée on fait une
place aux spectacles artistiques produit
par différentes communautés
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
et
le train et le quart sont venus
ponctuellement épauler les marcheurs
pour réduire les plus grandes distances
si le nord de la france a eu sa part de
la marche les régions qui ne figurait
pas sur le parcours n'ont pas été
oubliés c'est ainsi que des marches de
solidarité se sont organisés en
particulier dans l'hérault et dans
l'ouest de la france
[Musique]
si la fatigue rend les jambes de plus en
plus lourdes l'idée de l'arrivée de plus
en plus présentes allège les souffrances
physiques
la déception des premiers pas n'est plus
qu'un vague souvenir comme l' envie de
tout laisser tomber n'est plus qu'un
mauvais cauchemar
[Musique]
où
les marcheurs ont réussi leur pari
insensé faire la preuve qu'il existe en
france un peuple nombreux à penser que
la cohabitation entre communautés
d'origines différentes est possible dans
la paix la non violence la justice et
l'égalité un jour
[Musique]
autant
un jour viendra
le dos rond
un jour
[Musique]
le fire au fond
un jeu
dépôt lui
les jcm euros
comme quoi tout
sur la plus haute tour
je
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut pour avait souillé on
passait dans les frais moi mes souliers
ont bien thiney la lune mes souliers ou
couché chez les faits et fait danser
plus tu
sur mes souliers
lourd des rochers de la boue des chants
et des pleurs de femmes je peux dire
qu'ils sont respectés le curé pays le
bon dieu
hélas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
vision je suis un membre de
l'association des sauvaginiers onion
router part évidemment on en rencontre
et
précisons bien sûr bon de la part de
certains qui étaient plus tôt match
qu'il fallait qu'ils voulaient pas que
que les étrangers soient insérés en
france mais
mais depuis comme à shanghai plus de
de fraternité que que deux gars qui
étaient contre je crois que ça concerne
pas que les maghrébins parce que le
racisme c'est du club une plaie qui nous
concerne tous tous les habitants de
l'hexagone qu'on soit français l'autre
est bon on sait sur ce qu'ils vivent le
plus profondément c'est ceux qui en
souffrent mais on est tous concernés si
on veut pas que notre société elle
glisse d'or dans ce fléau du racisme
s'est créé un ami je le raconte la
marche et raconte ce qu'on fait
save a appris à me connaître les
immigrés puis surtout à mieux connaître
leurs problèmes
ce qu'on fait on le sait par les
journaux et c'est pas toujours la vérité
il ya trop d'injustice les assassins ne
sont pas punis on est au bout de six
mois on les relâche
mais moi je trouve que ça c'est pas
c'est inadmissible enfants
tom vivre en amour
il n'y aura plus de misère
les soldats seront tous bannu
[Musique]
e
cheveux au vent
mon frère
e
[Musique]
je de bouteilles sacs et vous tu peux tu
me laisses
je me suis
je veux recommencer ma vie j'ai traîné
j'entendais café j'ai fait là
jeudi soir les temps sont durs
je suis même pas dieu ni payer tout va
pas je vais changer quelque chose à moi
laveur je m'en suis aperçu pendant les
quelques jours où j'étais à bord de la
marche mais
certainement dans tout le groupe et même
d'un tout le pays ne pourra plus être
pareil ça va réveiller georges procès je
suis plein de confiance pour moi
y a plus qu'une chose qui compte est bon
dans la vie est saturé et et savait
surtout maintenant c'est cette lutte
contre le racisme qu'on voit partout
partout toi moi j'ai compris ça à
besançon
je vais un type qui m'a dit j'ai vu la
marche pas c est ben j'ai juré sur la
tête de ma femme je ne serai plus jamais
passer le mot raciste
georges en eurasie
non mais on attend un faut vous dépêcher
[Musique]
car sur permanent et
leur a cédé des gens qui sont dans le
suisse du fond des étapes avec nous
voilà marché
ashley
ça fait maintenant deux
depuis octobre depuis
sympathique et vous arrivez à paris le 2
donc ça va
ils arrivent ils arrivés là ah oui ça y
est
garde du québec à tous la bienvenue dans
la cité mais parce que moi je trouve que
j'ai très peur le dialogue est la chose
la chose qui arrive on insère des jeunes
parce que je sais que j'aime 104
stéphane de très bonnes choses il faut
non seulement il faut leur donner la
possibilité
et pour ça il faut les aider pour nous
on veut bien essayer de faire quelque
chose mais sauf qu'il faut qu'il faut
les aider que je vous assure que là vous
aurez des résultats de bon résultat
c'est parce qu'il est bon mais c'est
parce qu'elle est bons et des mauvais
partout
il vaut mieux ils vont mettre quelque
chose en place l'envoyé si vous voyez
vraiment ce que j'ai vraiment dû
retarder mingam échec y en a partout
pareil à ses excellentes
moi j'espère pas pour ça que déjà même
musée maguette nous ont donné une
mauvaise donne une mauvaise image pour
la guette les avait du boulot même non
pas tant à se présenter un boulot et
voilà où certaines avaient deviné ce et
du monde entier sait que j'appris
excusez moi je vous faisais mais en fait
c est ce que rapporte mosquée parce que
vous allez pouvoir parent masculin parce
qu'elle est ce parce qu'on dit justement
tu es côtés de la coi d'un agriculteur
en france mais est-ce que vous avez là
dessus je vois pas ce que j'ai ce parce
que en fait pas la différence entre une
mosquée et un local au yen à ça tu es
l'un quelques-unes
est ce parce que c'est la drôme en laye
à la sautée roman roman après balancer
mais est ce que moi je pense que la
mosquée c'est un truc que tu es un truc
vachement important pour les problèmes
par son ami parce que pour son vécu
toute leur vie bon il faut qu'il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose
bon il faut pas qu'il reste pour les
abonnés comme ça alors doucement la
mosquée wave une mosquée c'est un outil
qu'on a tenu dans une tour auprès des
cônes et le musc et ses mosquées ses
passes et une mosquée c'est drôle votre
esprit que nous communique dessus tout
comme n'importe quoi comme une synagogue
région en a discuté avec des jeunes on a
discuté avec des jeunes qui nous ont dit
vous voyez pas comme ça passe comment il
voyait expliquez moi comment le voyez
[Musique]
ces trucs qu'on combat enfin la non
violence
m
et tous les gens qu'on a pu raconter
[Musique]
bisous pas apparemment ça m'aurait
jamais arrivé par par la violence soit
le frère autant d'amis aussi toi
[Musique]
sous croyait un peu de cet hommage à
leur travail que moi je travaille les
coups que j'ai bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre marche est pour nous comme un cri
du coeur pour la dignité de tous les
hommes
et je vous dis que creil ne veut pas de
racisme car partout où le racisme s'est
développée là les hommes ont été
opprimés et ça a été le début du facisme
contre les crimes racistes et contre le
fascisme
je suis venu vous apporter le soutien
des élus et de toutes les associations
de creil s'adresse à l'homme à l'être
humain ce que chacun nous avant d'être
atteint 12 averti on est d'abord un être
humain et ça ça qu'on s'adresse certes
oups à la masse
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que nos détracteurs ils
s'entendent pour nous dénigrer car nous
pouvons être à la fois des feignants et
des valeurs de travail
nous avons pris la route et humains
comme nous à l'entrée le droit de
réponse
nous avons décidé de faire un long
périple aux portes de l'hiver peut
parler aux gens de ce pays
nous avons fait prise de 1300 km à pied
et bill kilomètres en train et en
voiture pour aller à la rencontre des
français
le moins que l'on puisse dire est que
nous jeunes issus de l'immigration nous
avons fait un pas dans un sens du
dialogue et nous posons la question
suivante aux français est ce que vous
ferez le second pas dans ce sens
je
quand on veut rentrer dans une boîte
dans un café va pas me demander ce qu on
est étudiant on est immigré
c'est pour ça que je suis ici parce que
je sais c'est défendre aussi mes frères
et mes soeurs
pourquoi cette démarche non violente
justement parce que jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on n'avait pas le droit de
réponse pendre de s'expliquer il y avait
des raisons de raisons de cette violence
c'était la taca notre dignité à notre à
notre fierté par le biais d'aidés bavure
policière
lens est rendu compte les tactiques on
n'était pas écouté qu'on n'était pas
entendu les matches qu'on donne et nous
était absolument plus ça m'a été
conscient très tôt mon avocat ou toutes
les possibilités de s'exprimer de on a
réalisé que par le biais de la non
violence
on avait
c'est tellement de meilleur moyen de
toucher le plus de shanghai ocs vraiment
que ce soit le mon pays le puisqu'on m'a
rejeté très souvent mais la france est
le pays où j'habite et où j'ai grandi et
anglais c'est ce que j'ai le droit d'y
vivre et j'ai encore plus adroits dire
que mes parents ont contribué à l'essor
économique de ce pays pour moi l'égalité
ces jours je me présente pourquoi
chercher du travail
on regardera pas si je suis noir profond
si je suis pour tuer mandat quelqu'un
qui veut chercher du travail
égalité aussi au niveau de l'éducation
parce qu'il ya aussi une séance au
niveau de l'éducation l'égalité devant
la justice c'est à dire les jeunes qui
se font aussi tué parce que assassiné je
dirais même et là il n'y a pas d'égalité
parce que quand on voit qu'un jeune qui
est qui fait un liquide comme les
de rien du tout qui va vous les quais un
petit truc il prend le maximum dans la
gueule quand je dirais est un assassin
qui va qui tue on lui mettra moyens de
relations ou trois mois on l'attendait
moi je trouve que le cas d'égalité la
croit savoir d'où tu viens je vais
marquer du sud d'afrique du sud c'est ça
oui tu peux défendre la marche
aujourd'hui et jaurès à vérone oui parce
que je suis arrivé en france il ya
quelques mois j'ai quitté l'afrique du
sud à cause de précision j'ai rendu
compte que deux précisément à détruire
mon pays alors je quittais l'afrique
cherche je suis venu en france
retrouver la liberté fait qualité et
jusqu'après je suis arrivé j'ai entendu
parler de les jeunes immigrés qui
étaient tués
et ça me choquer beaucoup parce que je
croyais que j'ai quittée j'ai quitté
leur assise et jamais chose pour
beaucoup parce que je trouvais trouver
ici en france un transilien type
d'apartés c'est pas dans la loi mais je
prends du contre il ya tous les partis
dans l'esprit de les françaises qui
commence tu se monte et alors quand j'ai
entendu parler de le march ce à la
veille d'une radio j'ai décidé de te
viens de me joindre à vous
[Musique]
est en train de marcher un matin il y
avait le brouillard
et on
marchais qu'il y avait un tas de sable
pas de sable de pelé et tout le monde et
marche et je voulais le prendre la main
et j'en ai mis quelques grands dans ma
foi je retiens main dans ma poche et
pour nous je ne les ai pas
quand on s'aime comme jardinier qu'il
faut gratter et enlever les mauvaises
herbes faire grandir la la plante la
plante les qualités
[Musique]
on a toujours beaucoup de jambes mais
des gens convaincus déjà depuis des
années combattez nous on leur donne une
occasion de de se montrer de discuter de
pompage et tout ce qu'ils ont fait est
là pour l'instant
mais les choses négatives je prends
l'exemple du mot reclast qui s'est passé
dans trappe
on n'a pas cherché les responsables et
nous marcherons marche pour pour salah
pour que nous farrar est de tomber et y
est il ya eu aucun aucun truc de concret
j'ai parlé avec des gens des
journalistes ddd god du gouvernement
tout le monde est passé à côté tout le
monde absolument tout le monde est passé
à côté voulu
partir tout il
marseille
début d'un marché vraiment parti je
dirais quoi
vraiment dans l'indifférence ne
s'endorme en partie tout outil de
marseille
les gens étaient plus ou moins tous les
bobards fassi s'attendait vraiment pas à
effacer un cortège silencieux
marche pour l'égalité
c'était un peu la curiosité
ce qu'on recherchait c'était l'effet
boule de neige c'est
en plus nous sommes montés plus les gens
à porter d'intérêt
la marche a effectué une marche partie
de marseille le 15 octobre et devant
arriver à paris le 3 décembre
bon j'aurais pu être j'aurais pu naître
en algérie ou au maroc la même chose que
j'aurais pu naître au liban sous les
bombes enfin je veux dire
moi j'essaye de lutter à mon niveau qui
est un niveau modeste bien sûr contre
l'injustice partout où elles se trouvent
dont il se trouve que malheureusement
des ports on est on n'a pas besoin
d'aller chercher à l'autre bout du monde
pour voir la justice puisque bon en
france on se rend compte qu'elle
existait chez nous donc voilà si j'avais
l'occasion de manifester quelque chose
c'est pour ça que je suis là
[Musique]
et comment on va rire à faire maintenant
rapide maintenant il faut qu'on discute
dans le toutes les régions plus pour le
3 décembre
on pousse à vous soit bien réussir ici
mais sans partis d'organisations
syndicales soit si difficile toutes et
tous je crois que je crois que notre
génération est grave mais il faut quand
même on va avec cette organisation
novalis d'une politique à paris la
question que je veux poser c'est en ce
qui concerne les gens qui sont des
marcheurs qui font partie de la marge
mais qui ne sont pas partis des
minguettes par exemple tout à l'heure
j'ai entendu une fille très courageuse
qui fait partie de la marche et qui est
de l'île
je la pose la question directement
quelles sont les raisons qui vous ont
poussé à participer à cette marche
je crois que ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
d'abord cela prendra ce poney parce
qu'on a peur les années
il semble moins personnellement j'ai
fait j'ai été élevé dans la dans la peur
des étrangers parce que parce que
j'avais une certaine conception de damas
copains
une certaine volonté de respect de tout
le monde j'ai voulu dépasser 100 mais
pendant longtemps j'ai essayé de
j'adore et une volonté d'effacer ça
maintenant je pleure pourquoi parce que
j'en connais beaucoup parce que je suis
j'ai beaucoup d'amis l'étranger parce
que je suis allé dans d'autres pays
parce que je me suis intéressé aux
autres religions est rejeté par les
caisses cas d'éruption au volcan mayon
politique de l'égalité qui dit qu'il
réussisse il faut qu'il ya un relais et
son relais ben c'est au rebut attendant
le syndicat pour le haut ceux qui sont à
la base sur les travailleurs également
la politique pour l'ensemble des
français
on a brisé pas dans la tranche en avant
c'est toute la politique on à mama
j'ai alors je les combats tout en étant
mère
du booker parler parce qu il est depuis
toujours je vais toujours vous gérez
vous le petit tout petit je vivais avec
les ingénieurs je me suis battu et les
jeunes
il est rationnel j'ai vécu avec eux je
dis que je suis un homme politique on
m'a dit tout à l'heure de l'internet
division ça je suis pas d'accord parce
que trop fait mon coeur je ne pense qu'à
une chose c'est que les hommes
quelles que soient leurs différences de
race d'opinion et trois lions ils ont
surtout vingt dix sont exploités
intérêts grands ensembles ecovadis a
vraiment l'intervention comme vous l'a
dit valentin
je croyais le malentendu dans tout le
monde on n'a jamais dit et je ne précise
que s'il n'y avait pas tous ces partis
politiques que s'il n'y avait pas tous
ces associations s'il n'y avait pas tout
le monde
on aurait fait quatre kilomètres on
aurait dit chez nous dormir ça je
précise et là il ya des malentendus
c'est devant nous quand on est parti de
la marche on faisait partie d'aucune
association d'aucun parti a invoqué un
parti mais un cours de route on à vix a
pris un sens politique qu'on le veuille
ou non
pande mais au dessus de toute l'image
mais on n'a jamais dit que monsieur ou
que monsieur que monsieur quoi ce qu'en
dit koné campoli connais pas politique
c'était dans le sens de partis
politiques
on est forcément politique c'est évident
c'est une démarche politique celle des
nouvelles je continue je pense que les
partis politiques et les syndicats aux
mets ton je sais pas comment appeler ça
une vocation si vous voulez on joue on a
vu ce qui n'est pas le nôtre ne veut pas
dire que le but des partis politiques et
des syndicats soulignent la soie
absolument un nul et inutile
ce n'est pas l'autre non je pense que
tous on est complémentaires et grelots à
marcher la main dans la main
[Musique]
je te vois
c'est que
on a eu à rencontrer beaucoup
d'organisation les partis politiques
d'associations
le grand collier je cherche à toucher
l'individu lui-même
[Musique]
c'est notre quant à nous je crois que
cette marche est sûre que nous avons
tous vécu comme une aventure
extraordinaire qui nous a qui nous a
liés les uns les autres ça va être très
très dur de se séparer
venu on a le sentiment si c'est le mot
qui revient rentreront je n'aurais
manqué qu'à une famille qui qu'est né à
ce moment là et nous sommes utiles c'est
cette famille que nous avons constitué
à l'occasion de ces sept semaines eh
bien elle est accessible à tous les
habitants c'est ce que je voudrais
pouvoir dire c'est que la fraternité
elle est possible quand on peut la
construire quand on compte on fait le
pari de construire et on souhaiterait
qu'elles que beaucoup de gens aient
envie de vis l'aventuré nous c'est une
joie énorme ce qu'on avait eues bruges
en imagine que c'est une épreuve
il ya un aspect mais ça mais ce n'est
rien à côté de tout ce qui ce qui est
vécu de tout ce qui est gagné
et puis cette marche il faut qu'elle ait
des lendemains et des uns et les autres
nous avons bien envie de dire de
continuer le combat ce qu est ce qu ils
sont humains fluo nous y tv mais nous
avons la ferme intention de continuer à
nous battre ensemble et avec tous ceux
que nous avons rencontrés pour que
l'égalité est soit vraiment une réalité
privée
maintenant la france ne peut plus être
j'avais pu être la même parce que
je suis sûr que dorénavant à chaque fois
qu'il y aura des tensions sur les
communautés à chaque fois qu'il y aura
des drames parce que malheureusement il
réunira d'autres agressions y aura
d'autres mains de cet inévitable dans la
situation de crise économique et morale
et d'identité que nous traversons il y
aura d'autres nam mais je suis sûr que
j'aurai ma vent on ne sauvera pas le
même silence la même indifférence parce
que ce qu'on a pu observer c'est vrai
moi dorénavant il ya des gens qui se
lèveront pour dire non nous ne sommes
pas d'accord ce n'est pas de cette
france-là plus loin je crois que à cause
de cette marche est bien les partis
traditionnels de droite qui
se sont laissés aller à des alliances
contre nature même s'ils sont de droite
ces partis sont souvent des partis qui
s'enracine dans la résistance il viendra
des partis qui ont accepté avec dreuil
particulièrement l'alliance avec des
groupes politiques qui sont des
nostalgiques du nazisme bien j'espère
qu'elle cause de cette marche ce type
d'alliance ne sera plus possible
[Musique]
la vidéo
et
on a décidé d'ouvrir à toulon de la même
marche
[Musique]
gestion de projets publics si les
personnes qui sont touchées étaient
présents ce soir fovu soyez le 3
décembre à la bastille vous avez aucune
excuse pour payet
tout y est convaincu ce soir fait passer
bon votre quotidien aux gens qui ne sont
pas
[Applaudissements]
sa mise en marche le 15 octobre de
marseille pour parcourir la france afin
d' d'appeler tous les français tous ceux
de communautés diverses à manifester
nombreux leur volonté de construire
ensemble une france multiculturelle
[Musique]
m
les
nous à nous décider
après lyon c'est lyon c'est l'étape
clé de lavage mais c'est là où on a
commencé à reprendre par an dès 10
heures
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il dit
la première moi j'ai choisi
ce qui passait à la la la
la une sports
l'intérieur
meilleur choix qui ne fléchit
si tu as
la solide
apa vient jamais
aujourd'hui pour assister au forum
justice qui rentre dans le cadre de la
manche à l'égalité des droits humains
bien que tous à la maison des jeunes la
culture avec les événements qui ont été
évités c'est les fans de cette dance the
beach je voudrais vous raconter tout
chauffard a peur que les jeunes quelques
correctifs john terry steven c'était
répondre
l'association génération de jeunes qui
est de bouger leur but à tous c'est là
toute cette neige a apporté un soutien
total plein l'auditionnaient à
l'entraînement la question est stable
avec une égale à tous les jeunes qui
veulent amener le marché et pour arriver
tant de joie à la belle poule
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens tués en force à paris à
marseille actuellement se souvenir
non
[Musique]
saint denis va c'est une municipalité
communiste cours assez importante et on
sent qu'on approche de paris parce que
vraiment ça ça devient très tendu très
nerveux en même temps c'est chouette
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde mais en
même temps c'est très difficile de
rester calme au milieu de tout ça oui
mais bon c'est bien je crois qu'il aura
beaucoup de monde de ma vie
ça bouillonnait d'un nous ça bouillonne
là on sait que demain ça va être une
belle journée on y croit je marche au
parti de marseille
arrivé à paris le 3 décembre place de la
bastille cette marche se veut avant tout
dénoncer tous les crimes et agressions
racistes tous les domaines de la vie
sociale au sein steurs la discrimination
oui nos marchands nous marchons pour
manifester qu'il ya en france un peuple
nombreux a doctement 1h ou 1h30 on sera
j'espère plus de 100 milles
[Musique]
et l'après marcheurs elle va commencer
exactement demain oui vous avez été
blessé dans un acte raciste vous êtes
donc aucun des chefs concernés par cette
démarche
pour vous qu'est ce qui a changé grâce à
cette marche eh ben je peux déjà
commencé à dire que à partir de cet
instant mais depuis que la marche est
partie on peut plus généralisée
parce que bon il se passe que on était
parti est en tête avec les français sont
plus ou moins tous racistes alors on n'a
plus le droit de généraliser on a eu
avoir eu des enfants qui viennent à
notre rencontre même jusqu'à voir un
policier porte et les cuissons marche
pour l'égalité halde
mais l'important c'est peut-être aussi
de sa part tellement vous allez vivre
les choses après bah écoutez le simple
fait d'être passée dans des villes et il
ya eu et uc après le passager eut des
associations de jeunes qui sont qui sont
créées il ya eu des idées des changes et
on va le faire en sorte de faire une
coordination nationale peut on les
change d'idée et un front anti raciste
et sa maman
oui
[Musique]
c'est du jamais vu
attention je n'en sais pas un sourire à
ceux d'un départ n'a pas du tout
l'intention d'avoir à l'esprit anciens
combattants a pas d'histoire
moi je verrais bien des petits arabes à
l'opérette chanté des chants et doux et
tout ça
[Musique]
je remercie énormément de tout mon coeur
que ce qui vaut pour tous les enfants
qui ont été tués
[Musique]
voilà
comment
le
jeudi à l'ats
je ne
nicolas
[Musique]
non
là
voilà
[Musique]
non
le jeu
depuis le
lieu
je ne
l'équipe
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous ferons ce
cher pays de mon enfant
ce
c'est de tendre insouciance eux
je n'ai gardé dans mon coeur
clash et aux maisons savez
[Musique]
enfant d'un an
partager mon bonheur
[Musique]
oui je t'aime
et je te donne ce poème
m dans la joie ou la douleur
tous ces français
frappé de mon enfant
[Musique]
grâce aux six ans
les gars étaient dans mon coeur
[Musique]
en revanche pour l'égalité et contre le
racisme
parti de marseille le 15 octobre est
aujourd'hui dans votre ville au terme
d'un périple de neuf mois et demi
la première manche pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme harry frère a pris le
train des cendres je fermerai l'écran le
doublement de la bastille à 14 heures
nous invitons les habitants et
habitantes de hors france et de ses
environs oui je te à venir nous
rejoindre nombreux à 14h 15h va
simplement qui regroupera tous ceux et
toutes celles qui veulent avec nous que
l'égalité des droits l'emportent sur la
ségrégation tous ceux qui vont mourir je
te les garder dans mon coeur le jeter
garder
non mon coeur
[Musique]
les devants pour demain
or gagner on arrive la chasse est fermée
français émigré égalité des droits égaux
avec nos différents noms à tous les
racistes sont pas plus à pierre les
siamoises et séjours formation emploi
logement égalité des droits
la société de demain se construit
aujourd'hui nous en faisons partie et
pour finir pour une france pluriethnique
et pluriculturelle aulas il faut qu'on
voie ce qu'on va peut-être mettre un
terme
techno non plus pourquoi la communauté
d'accueil bonjour oui de damas vas y
aura une soirée 2
de la vera 24 heures a trouvé toutes
nationalités qui y est maghrébin
portugais rui silva comité parisien avec
pour la marche d'un jour
[Musique]
j'ai marché sur bien des routes j'ai
connu bien et patelin a tous envie dans
le doute
partout on attend la fin j'ai vu occuper
ma ville par des comptes d'uniformes qui
n'était pas vraiment viril mais qui se
prenait pour des hommes j'ai chanté dix
fois cent fois
[Musique]
j'ai crié
la société
[Musique]
tu m'auras pas j'ai vu tous ces débats
ricane j'ai vu pleurer mes copains
entendu les chronos
un petit
j'ai lu ce que tu
faisait
un blog qui vit pour toi j'ai connu
l'absurdité de la morale
[Musique]
chanter
sans voix j'ai hurlé
[Applaudissements]
c'est que je pense
[Musique]
tu m'as
demeurant gare
afoa ton fric à ton goût l'an
la vérité
agra
commune refleurira
mais on en a
je chante et je te crache à la gueule
cette petite chanson mais
ce que tu écoutes dans ton fauteuil j'ai
chanté 10 fois
cent fois
les mots
j'ai crié
que je pense
[Musique]
tu m'auras pas
voici ces mêmes
il
[Musique]
vas-y encore
ses cheveux
ce qui serait là
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
schumi est aspiré par la marche de
gandhi sa façon de combattre le racisme
de par la non violence et cette marche
qui l'inspiré c'est sur son lit
d'hôpital qu'il a eu l'idée de lancer un
peu la jirs comme ça en rigolant pas
danser pris au mot on a mis trop quatre
membres concrétiser la marche notamment
pendant le long du grand rassemblement
s'est étiolée un sac
on a fait des conférences de presse à
paris sur les partis
[Musique]
où
nous
b
et
[Musique]
il
à
j'avance
non
[Applaudissements]
je
jamais
pas
[Musique]
genre
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
ans
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
à
nous se pensent eux
cher pays de mon enfance je
[Musique]
e
ceux-ci ans
c'est
des gardes et donc
[Musique]
la sheo maison ça
je
partager mon bonheur
oui je t'ai
[Musique]
te donne ce poème
non là je vois au la douleur
où je prends je
c'est râpé de mon enfant
hanches et de tendre un saw 6 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime
et je te donne ce point
[Musique]
oui je t'aime
dans
k
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
-
[Musique]
il
parce que vous nous gêner pour la
protection alors jeunes d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et fier catalogne ou quoi l'été
zaïtsev
[Musique]
mais kate mathiesen
le racisme est entre nous et on au
milieu de chacun d'entre nous une
permanent il ya toute forme de racisme
je veux dire donc que ce soit quelques
gamins comme ça qu'ils réveillent 7
consciences endormies tête en chacun de
nous est quelque chose pour moi de
merveilleux son ensemble émigrés et
français nous venons ici les français
dans cette tâche admirable et signé de
la france que de la tâche ont souhaité
la réconciliation à tendance religieuse
entre tous les soirs nous sommes tous
égaux
[Musique]
n
mondiale
salah
pialat
à
[Applaudissements]
il y a un semblant et ce qui est plus
qu'un semble enfin une majorité de
français qui disent ça suffit les et les
immigrés les étrangers sont avec nous
ils travaillent avec nous il participe
avec nous toutes les manifestations
d'hostilité que l'on a pu voir des
crimes abominables quand on peut voir
aux révoltés d'ensemble des français
croient que c'est ça qui est
significatif c'est un motif d'espoir
c'est un motif d'espoir et ça montre
bien que l'ensemble des français et
l'ensemble des immigrés envie de marcher
ensemble comme nous marchons ensemble
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les violets
pasta main
[Musique]
sa formidable je me dis que les
passerelles etc
le peuple français
le peuple français c'est pas le goff qui
tire aux fenêtres avec une 22 long rifle
c'est aussi ces gens là la formule
chômeurs
[Musique]
mathieu
on voit le monde cas aujourd'hui moi ça
me remonte le moral
je pense que les français ne sont pas
racistes globalement et qu'il fallait
qu'il le prouve aujourd'hui ils le
prouvent
[Musique]
et je suis très heureuse de participer à
ce qui est aujourd'hui une manifestation
d'amitié voit qu'il ya un sursaut dans
ce pays et que nous allons vaincre la
haine et la violence ça donne chaud au
coeur de voir qu'autant de gens sont
venus spontanément se joindre à cette
marche
ce qui est extraordinaire dans cette
marche et moi je salue cette initiative
c'est qu'elle apporte la preuve une fois
de plus que comme la marche des noirs
comme les marches des femmes
il ya des initiatives populaires qui
partent de la base en dehors des partis
et qui finalement rassemble toutes les
volontés de lutte contre ce phénomène
aussi monstrueux qu'est le racisme
[Musique]
ah ah
pour m à madame royal ivernel pour les
menaces à la liberté où les attaques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
benjamin raich aut à 0
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
kate mathiesen
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en route pour ce pour ce qui est
de la carte de 10 ans il ya déjà un pas
vers l'égalité est votre bilan de cette
marche qu'est ce que ça a changé pour
vous ben ça a changé une chose qu'on
peut plus demeurer à généraliser il faut
plus jamais généraliser on peut plus
dire que les français sont racistes
le fait qu'il ya des gens de quelqu'un
qu'elle cache qui soit ils sont venus
marcher avec nous on peut plus
généralisée le fait que qu'un policier a
appelé un autocollant de la marche on
peut plus dire que les policiers sont
tous à l'eau tous deux nous valent
aujourd'hui est bien un peuple nombreux
s'est levé pour dire non à cette
gangrène du racisme je crois que c'est
le premier grand bilan le deuxième c'est
que les jeunes ont montré qu'ils étaient
là qu'il faisait partie de ce pays qu'il
fallait les entendre et beaucoup de gens
ont témoigné qu'ils acceptaient de les
entendre et de la reconnaître comme
faisant partie de ce pays et puis je
crois que cette marche est là elle a
soulevé
de grands espoirs je crois que déjà en
retrouver leur dignité des gens qui
disaient la france c'est foutu aussi
bien les français que que des comme les
gens d'origine étrangère bien maintenant
c'est 10 mais non c'est pas foutu
relevant la tête jours
[Musique]
on va gagner une partie grande partie
même si la population
on est dans la bonne voie
[Musique]
il faut marcher encore j'ai pas pas
d'employer ces mots c'est un passé
historique
[Musique]
j'étais très ému je sais pas quoi dire